und jetzt geht es hier im parlament
weiter mit dem einzelplan 15 gesundheit
also dem etat von karl lauterbach und es
ist kein wunder nach der entwicklung der
letzten zeit lisa etat ist mit 11,76
milliarden aufstockung bei 64 3 6
milliarden so groß wie noch nie zuvor
der etat für ein gesundheitsminister war
und zwar war er zum beispiel im
vergleich im letzten jahr beim
49,9 milliarden der größte posten bei
diesen 64 36 milliarden ist mit abstand
der gesundheitsfonds 30 milliarden euro
und der erste redner ist der vorsitzende
des haushaltsausschusses hilde braun von
der cdu
wir haben in deutschland eines der mit
besten gesundheitssysteme der welt
darauf können wir sehr stolz sein und
darüber können wir auch sehr froh sein
dass wir ein so gutes gesundheitssystem
haben das rückgrat des ganzen sind die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in den
gesundheitsberufen ärzte pflegende
medizinische heilberufe rettungsdienst
und viele andere und mit dem
bundeshaushalt haben wir eine aufgabe
auch dieses gesundheitssystem
zukunftsfest zimmer vor uns liegt ein
bundeshaushalt mit einem mit
historischen ausgaben für den bereich
der gesundheit aber es ist ein haushalt
der eigentlich alle wesentlichen
zukunftsfragen unseres
gesundheitssystems
unbeantwortet ist wegen hoher ausgaben
nach wie vor für die bewältigung der
korona pandemie wir haben hohe abstrakte
zuschüsse für den bereich der gkv und
der pflege aber die eigentlichen
reformprojekte auch gerade das vom
bundesgesundheitsminister angekündigte
gkv stabilisierungsgesetz liegt noch
nicht vor und auch in der
mittelfristigen finanzplanung des
finanzministers gibt es für die
mitarbeitenden
gesundheitssystem nicht einen einzigen
hinweis wo die fahrt eigentlich hin geht
sondern wenn man in die mittelfristige
finanzplanung schaut dann muss man sich
eigentlich eher sorgen machen weil der
finanzminister offenkundig davon ausgeht
dass im nächsten jahr wieder eine
situation haben wir 2009 10 keine kosten
für die pandemie keine zusätzlichen
kosten für die stabilisierung der der
pflege oder der krankenversicherung
sondern ein status quo ante und jeder
weiß das wird nicht passieren das heißt
dieser einzelplan ist ein großes risiko
für die finanzierung der kommenden jahre
aber er lässt wirklich die
zukunftsperspektive für die patienten
für die versicherten und auch für die
mitarbeitenden in der im gesamten
gesundheitssystem völlig offen
reden wir zum beispiel über die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung der
gkv-spitzenverband geht davon aus dass
wir im kommenden jahr eine lücke haben
werden von 17 milliarden euro das
entspreche wenn man es über eine
beitragserhöhung abwickeln würde einer
zunahme von einem ganzen prozentpunkt im
bereich der gkv das reformgesetz haben
wir bis heute noch in diesem jahr haben
wir in der gesetzlichen
pflegeversicherung
eine lücke von bis zu 3,6 milliarden
euro das was hier im haushalt abgebildet
sind sind rund zwei drittel davon
der gesetzliche zuschuss plus 1,2
milliarden zusätzlich mehr aber auch
nicht dass noch in diesem jahr besteht
handlungsbedarf im bereich der
pflegeversicherung
ganz besonders große sorgen mache ich
mir ehrlich gesagt und die
krankenhausfinanzierung
ich hab das mehrfach gesagt ist es
wichtig dass die ausgleichszahlungen
auslaufen aber das grundproblem das seit
jahren die länder im bereich der
krankenhausinvestitionen nicht genügend
geld finanzieren und der kostendruck im
bereich des dia des systems dazu führt
dass wir eine dauerhafte
unterfinanzierung unseres krankenhaus
systems haben die konsequenz sind die
ober arbeitsbelastung des personals die
konsequenz ist dass auch moderne aus
statt fehlt die alte regierungskoalition
hatte dazu mit dem zukunftsprogramm für
die krankenhäuser mit einer jan einen
startschuss gesetzt sie könnten jetzt
auch was anderes machen sie müssen sich
dieses programm fortführen aber wenn ich
in diesem haushalt schaue 0 euro und
auch kein alternatives konzept für die
zukunft der krankenhausfinanzierung was
wir dringend gebraucht hätten
[Applaus]
während wir hier sind diskutieren die
ministerpräsidenten und der
bundeskanzler über die frage wie wir uns
pandemisch auf den herbst vorbereiten
wenn man in diesem haushalt schaut
stellt man fest dass viele finanzierungs
tatbestände wie zum beispiel für tests
zur jahresmitte zwar enden und die
alternative könnte ja sein dass wir in
diesem haushalt eine vorstellung finden
wie wir uns in zukunft auf pandemien und
anderes besser einstellen dass die
initiative des robert-koch-instituts die
100 seiten konzept aufgestellt haben wie
sie sich die zukunft ihres instituts
vorstellen sind weder finanziell noch
personell in diesem haushalt abgebildet
das heißt die grundsätzliche reform des
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienstes findet
sich im haushalt genauso wenig wieder
wie zum beispiel auf eine weiter und
dauer finanzierung unserer
schutzausrüstung notreserve dafür sind
im haushalt genau null euro vorgesehen
das heißt das was wir jetzt haben wird
durch zeitablauf her entwertet dadurch
dass verwendung zeiträume ablaufen nach
finanzierung ist nicht vorgesehen das
heißt auch unsere nationale reserve wird
irgendwann verschwinden und ein konzept
für die zukunft wie es auch in anträgen
im haushalt gefordert haben gibt es
nicht genauso gibt es keine antwort auf
die frage der zukünftigen
der des zukünftigen möglichkeit wie wir
meinen bekämpfen etwas effektiver werden
es gibt im deutschen bundestag eine
breite mehrheit die bereit wäre ein impf
register einzuführen und wir wissen dass
es nicht nur eine frage von pandemie
vorsorge ist sondern wenn man die
stellungnahme des ethikrats sich
anschaut dann ist ein impf register für
die surveillance im olymp surveillance
in unserem land für die effektive
datennutzung für die verbesserung des
gesundheitssystems insgesamt und der
gesundheitlichen versorgungslage der
bevölkerung sinnvoll wir haben angeregt
dass wir hier für eine finanzierung
bereitstellen die koalition hat das
abgelehnt und der gesundheitsminister
stellt dazu fragen statt konzepte und
antworten zu liefern
und deshalb muss ich sagen für die
beschäftigten für die für die
versicherten aber auch für die
patientinnen und patienten sie hat
einfach dieser haushalt keine
zukunftsperspektive und das war können
wir eben in der vorliegenden form auch
nicht zustimmen
helge brauchen der ehemalige
kanzleramtsminister jetzt vorsitzender
des haushaltsausschusses selber ja auch
arzt geht hier hart ins gericht mit dem
entwurf des
bundesgesundheitsministers karl
lauterbach keine zukunfts fragen werden
beantwortet das fehlt zum beispiel das
gkv stabilisierungsgesetz und nun karl
lauterbach dem bundesminister
[Musik]
daher von hier meine grüße meine
bestellung an ihm wir werden ihn
unterstützen bei der beschaffung von
prothesen für die vielen menschen auch
kinder die gliedmaßen verloren haben der
ukraine wir werden helfen
traumazentren und brand
versorgungszentren aufzubauen wir werden
alles tun was wir können um die ukraine
zu unterstützen damit das morden an
kindern an unschuldigen menschen dort
endet und werden alles tun damit dieser
krieg dieses furchtbare elend für die
ukraine siegreich beendet werden kann
mit 64 milliarden euro ist das der
größte haushalt den würdigen so das
bundesgesundheitsministerium eingebracht
haben ist der zweitgrößte haushalt aller
ministerien und es ist ein haus hat auf
der einen seite pandemie kosten abdeckt
auf der anderen seite aber auch in die
zukunft blickt wir haben jetzt hat eine
spielen bestimmung die sich im prinzip
durch drei unterschiedliche
blicke schreiben des vorstands haben wir
diejenigen die glauben die party ist
vorbei wir können zur normalität
zurückkehren die panini hat
stattgefunden wir können wieder dort war
danach nur 2009 10 waren dann gibt es
diejenigen die unsicher sind diejenigen
die sehen da können auch andere
varianten kommen wir wissen nicht wie
gut die impfstoffe wirken werden wissen
nicht ob wir eine omikron variante
bekommen wasser bekommen also die
unsicherheiten sehen und die dritte
gruppe ist diejenige wir glauben wir
werden probleme haben die besorgt sind
die zum beispiel nach südafrika schauen
dort die a 445 fälle sehen die db a 5
bälle in portugal sehen die sehen dass
bei uns die inzidenz nicht mehr so
zuverlässig zurückgeht wie in der
vergangenheit und die auch sehen dass
wir weiterhin 50 bis 100 tote pro tag
haben wir müssen diese drei gruppen
zusammenführen und was alle drei gruppen
miteinander ein was unsere pflicht ist
wo wir ansetzen wir dürfen nicht erneut
unvorbereitet wie im letzten herbst in
die krise gehen wir müssen gut
vorbereitet sein wir können es uns sich
leisten ein weiterer
unvorbereiteter herbst wäre nicht
vertretbar wären daher sechs dinge tun
wir werden zum einen ein konzept haben
und dieses im konzept wird vor sind dass
wir für alle varianten bekommen können
den richtigen impfstoff haben wir werden
wo hahn im stoff haben wir werden bei
micon impfstoff haben und wir werden
kombinierten impfstoff haben wir wissen
dass im herbst alle den besten impfstoff
haben wollen es wird niemanden geben der
dann sagt ich nehme den zweitbesten
impfstoff oder den drittbesten impfstoff
das heißt wir werden so viel impfstoff
beschaffen dass wir alle drei gruppen
bedienen können das wird doch dazu
führen dass wir impfstoff vernichten
müssen aber wir sind so abgesichert für
alle möglichkeiten und das ist was die
bevölkerung wünscht zum zweiten
wir werden eine test strategie haben die
darauf hinausläuft dass wir nicht nur
testen um die famitsu beobachten sondern
das testen wird auch ein bestandteil der
reduktion der fälle seien wir werden
eine behandlungsstrategie haben wo wir
schneller die medikamente die wirken zum
beispiel paket an die patienten bringen
wir haben diese medikamente derzeit wir
nutzen sie aber nicht so wie sie genutzt
werden könnten das heißt sie werden an
behandlungskonzept auch wir werden die
variablen gruppen deutlich besser
schützen insbesondere in
pflegeeinrichtungen aber auch die
immunsupprimierten wir werden ein neues
infektionsschutzgesetz aufbauen wir
werden nachher in dann also
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz darüber
noch einmal also zu diskutieren haben
daran werde ich nach diesen sitzungen
teilnehmen und wir werden darüber hinaus
auch bessere daten haben werden daten
haben tagesgenau zu den freien betten
auf den intensivstation auf den
peripheren stationen den coffee
patienten auf diesen stationen so dass
wir eine präzisere anbindung des
sogenannten dem des systems an das
robert-koch-institut haben so dass wir
eine viel bessere
datenübersicht haben als wir das hatten
ich komme jetzt
ich komme jetzt zu den punkten die hat
zurecht verbrauchen angemahnt worden
sind was also wir zu tun haben das ist
in der tat richtig dass wir an defizit
was ich geerbt habe sie haben eben nicht
erwähnt das ist ja ein defizit was ich
von meinem vorgänger geerbt habe von 17
milliarden euro die ausgaben sind ja in
den vier jahren meines vorgängers um 45
milliarden pro jahr pandemie bereinigt
gestiegen somit erbe ich ein großes
defizit und ich bitte einfach
unverständlich ich lasse mich da auch
nicht drängen ich will dieses
historische defizit
beseitigen ohne das ich leistungen
kürzen werde daher dauert das etwas aber
das haben wohl eher stolz und ich
zugesagt es wird nichts zu
leistungskürzungen kommen und trotzdem
werden wir dieses defizit werden wir
dieses defizit ausgleichen zum zweiten
sich an die krankenhaus reform
angekündigt und die kranken aus reform
hat begonnen
die kommission krankenhaus reform
expertenkommission hat die arbeit
aufgenommen
die ersten drei bereiche die
abgearbeitet werden sind die herausnahme
der kinderheilkunde unter geburtshilfe
aus der partie und die bessere
notfallversorgung alle drei bereiche
werden abgearbeitet ich nehme an den
sitzungen selbst teil wir werden die
expertenkommission in den nächsten
wochen da vorschläge habt noch vor der
sommerpause werden wir auch die
beratungen an daten
gesundheitsministerium die fraktionen
werden von anfang an beteiligt aber auch
die länder so dass wir an
reißverschlusssystem haben immer neue
ratschläge und dann politische
bearbeitung mit diesen drei bänken wir
werden sie auf dem laufen hatten sie
aber sie werden das viel erwarten wir
lassen die kranken aus reform nicht
liegen und sie haben recht das also in
der letzten legislaturperiode über die
notwendigkeit an der krankenhaus
reformen gesprochen worden ist aber was
kann ich mir von diesen gesprächen
kaufen was hier was helfen wir gespräche
ich kann nur soviel sagen
einfach ausgedrückt was die krankenhaus
reform angeben das war ja auch in der
krankheit strukturreform 2015 so bin ich
ehrlich gesagt eher ein mann der tat aus
der großen worte somit sie werden sehen
wir werden dort einiges wir werden dort
einig wir werden doch einiges sehen
verlassen sie sich auf meine worte
zum dritten wir werden auch wir werden
auch etwas machen für die
unterversorgten wird gebetet wir haben
in der pandemie gesehen dass in den
sozialen brennpunkten die meisten
sterbefälle die vermeidbar gewesen sind
aufgetaucht sind wir haben dort
erhebliche probleme gab und ich möchte
einfach ein konzept aufbauen dass wir in
den unterversorgten gebieten aktiv
werden und zwar dass wir mit
gesundheitskosten niederschwelligen
angeboten gesundheitskosten wo menschen
sprachbarrieren überwinden wo man sich
informieren kann wo man termine besorgen
hat dass man dort auflaufen kann wir
werden mit der community hessen wo es
auch einen neuen
heilberufen bringen so dass wir dort
eine struktur aufbauen die einfach eine
andockstelle ist für diejenigen die
sprachbarrieren haben die einkommens
barrieren haben die aber unserer hilfe
bedürfen das wird eine priorität sind da
werde ich ein vorschlag noch vor der
sommerpause vorlegen und schließlich wir
werden ein pflege entlastungsgesetz
machen der grundgedanke ist der die der
pflegenotstand wir gehen ja mal darüber
der muss ja beseitigt werden und ein
instrument ist das folgende wir werden
den pflegebedarf bemessen wahrscheinlich
mit dem instrument ppr zu 3.0 das ist
ein bedarfs- instrument da können wir
den
pflegebedarf abschätzen und wir können
das dann vergleichen mit der pflege die
bezahlt wird weil wir die pflege über
selbst kostendeckungsprinzip aus der
letzten legislaturperiode
eingeführt ja wissen wir wissen wer
pflegt wo wir kennen die bedarfe und aus
dieser diskrepanz können wir dann die
überlastung der einzelnen abteilungen
und krankenhäuser abladen und daraus
können wir dann noch entsprechende
schlüsse ziehen wie es weitergeht da
kann es zum beispiel darauf hinauslaufen
dass wir das für die krankenhausplanung
nutzen es kann dann darauf hinauslaufen
dass bestimmte abteilungen bestimmte
leistungen nicht mehr erbringen können
war das nur zu lasten des
pflegepersonals mögliches mit dem
qualitäts einschränkungen wir haben wir
überlegen uns etwas natürlich mit der
expertenkommission gemeinsam wie wir
pflege entlastung nicht als schlagwort
sondern als konkrete umsetzung möglich
machen auch daran wird noch vor der
sommerpause gearbeitet lassen sie nicht
an dieser stelle sagen möchte ich
ausdrücklich sagen ich habe zu ihm
gesagt wir haben diesen riesenhaus hut
gehabt ich habe den immer wieder
vorgetragen und wir haben lange
miteinander diskutiert die art und weise
wie diese diskussion gelaufen ist war
sehr kollegial das möchte ich einfach
sagen daher meinen dank an alle
staatstragenden parteien hier im haus an
allen staatstragenden parteien es war
eine sehr gute diskussion ich habe es
ihnen nicht immer leicht gemacht und
auch umgekehrt aber das hat wirklich los
weitergebracht somit da haben wir
gegenseitig gelernt vielen dank an die
haushälter und ich freue mich auf die
nächsten runden stand für die
aufmerksamkeit
karl lauterbach der
bundesgesundheitsminister der hier noch
einmal seine politik vorgestellt hat
unter anderem hat er gesagt er wird noch
bis zur sommerpause ein konzept für
unterversorgte gebiete vorliegen
der nächste redner kommt jetzt von der
afd
der gesundheitspolitische sprecher
erhalten sichert
mit ihrer politik treiben sie viele
menschen in die verzweiflung
tausende sterben weil sie keinen termin
beim facharzt finden anstatt sich um die
gesundheitsversorgung zu kümmern
klingeln sie lieber von talkshow zu
talkshow oder treten als stand up
comedian bei amazon auf ich freue mich
für sie wenn sie darin ihre berufung
sehen aber seien sie dann doch bitte
konsequent und legen sie das amt des
gesundheitsministers endlich nieder
dieser haushalt ist kein haushalt für
gesundheit sondern ein pharma und
lobbyisten haushalt mit diesem haushalt
werden einige protagonisten im
gesundheitswesen richtig reich auf
kosten der bürger beispielsweise gibt
die regierung alleine für § 21
krankenhaus finanzierungsgesetz 4,6
milliarden aus das ist der paragraph
dann dem krankenhäuser umso mehr geld
bekommen je weniger intensivbetten sie
als verfügbar melden bundesrechnungshof
und rk ii haben letztes jahr schon davor
gewarnt dass diese regelung
krankenhäuser zum betrug verführt die
regierung ignoriert das denn so kann sie
weiter milliarden an jene verteilen die
helfen panik zu verbreiten die ampel
agiert die ampel agiert wie ein
absolutistischer herrscher aus dem
mittelalter steuergeld wird ein
willfährige verfallen verteilt der
nutzen der bürger spielt für sie keine
rolle wo die prioritäten der regierung
liegen kann man daran erkennen dass der
gesundheitsminister mehrfach im
haushaltsausschuss aber nur ein einziges
mal im gesundheitsausschuss anwesend
waren nämlich also wunder um den
haushalt ging herr lauterbach ihr job
ist nicht geld für lobbyisten zu
beschaffen sondern sich um elementare
probleme der gesundheitsversorgung zu
kümmern sie geben dieses jahr 50
milliarden mehr aus als 2009 10 haben
aber nicht mal ein paar millionen für
eine vernünftige evaluierung übrig weil
sie die evaluierung fürchten dass durch
die korona maßnahmen nachweislich
millionen menschen psychisch erkrankt
sind ignorieren sie psychisch erkrankte
mussten schon vor corona monatelang auf
behandlungstermine warten inzwischen
bekommen viele erst nach einem halben
jahr wenn überhaupt einen termin bei
einem therapeuten sie herr lauterbach
tun nichts um die wartezeit bei
fachärzten zu reduzieren genauso wie sie
nichts tun um den pflegemangel zu
beseitigen und nichts für eine bessere
ärztliche versorgung auf dem land wir
von der afg sind dagegen aber milliarden
zu verschwenden damit einige richtig
absahnen können insbesondere da
millionen bürger aufgrund gestiegener
lebenshaltungskosten überhaupt nicht
mehr wissen wie sie ihr tägliches leben
finanzieren können die 50 milliarden die
man hier aus gibt für die lobbyisten und
für die pharma- dafür können sie man
beispielsweise den bürgern und den
unternehmen sechs jahre lang sämtliche
rundfunkgebühren erlassen wir werden
diesen haushalt für pharma und
lobbyisten ablehnen
apropos rundfunkgebühren meine damen und
herren ich würde es nochmal versuchen
phoenix extra ein spezielles angebot auf
hbbtv
präsentiert ihnen hoffentlich jetzt um
viertel nach drei die
ministerpräsidenten die heute in berlin
zusammen getreten sind und unter anderem
über die reform des medien
staatsvertrages sprechen werden wir
werden hier im tv-sender ganz normal
weiter bei dieser debatte über den
gesundheitsetat bleiben und das treffen
mit dem bundeskanzler ist verschoben auf
16 uhr irgendwann anschließend wird es
eine pressekonferenz dann mit dem
bundeskanzler und ministerpräsidenten
geben auch die werden sie live hier bei
uns im fernsehen sehen paula quichotte
jetzt für die bündnisgrünen
er sagt jetzt kommen ja gleich die
grünen die grünen die immer nur die
krise sehen die grünen die immer die
schwarzmalerei der zukunft betreiben ich
ganz ehrlich dass man das heutzutage wo
sich zum beispiel diese voraussage
bezüglich der gkv finanz nicht als
richtig erwiesen hat immer noch uns
vorwerfen kann wir werden nicht
realistisch und selber seine eigene
rosarote brille nicht erkennen zum
beispiel weil fehlen denn so liegen
vorsorge für eine gute gkv finanzierung
das kann ich nicht verstehen und das
trage ich nicht wie lange sie noch in
der opposition stießen damit man ihn
wieder dieses soziale sicherungssysteme
überhaupt anschauen kann so zurück zum
thema was sind denn in diesen tagen die
schlagzeilen im gesundheitswesen 10.000
unbesetzten pflegestellen aber auch die
tatsache dass viele sich jetzt wo sie
ganz viele kollegen im gesundheitswesen
verloren haben fragen wie lange sie es
noch mit sich machen lassen drei von
vier wochenenden jeden monat dienst zu
schrubben das sind schlagzeilen aber
auch zum beispiel diesen montag
amtsgericht freiburg dasteht und 20
jähriger vor gericht der letzten august
einen monat vor der bundestagswahl noch
bei seiner kassenärztlichen vereinigung
vor ort 5,7 millionen geltend gemacht
hat als corona tests die ihr im ersten
halbjahr 20 21 durchgeführt haben wollte
der hat es angemeldet und dass er diese
tests jemals gemacht hat bei der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung die hat das
durchgewunken bundesamt für soziale
sicherung hat es ausgezahlt und erst die
bank die diesen eingang von 5,7
millionen gesehen hat hat verdacht
geschöpft und hat das mal gemeldet da
wurde jetzt verurteilt was fällt heute
der kassenärztlichen vereinigung dazu
dazu ein die sagt ich zitiere sie sei ja
keine ermittlungsbehörde
es ging ja eher darum viele tests in die
fläche zu bringen als ordentlich zu
kontrollieren da müssen die natürlich
als haushälter land nicht nur weil das
geld ist was an anderer stelle fehlt
sondern weil das natürlich auch den
menschen in unserem land und den
patientinnen und patienten das gefühl
gibt hier ist geld im gesundheitswesen
noch und nöcher da nur für die falschen
dinge
deswegen bin ich mein mit haushälterin /
l und karsten klein sehr dankbar dass
wir unter anderem die maßgabe auf den
weg bringen konnten das genau für diese
corona testzentren die finanzierung im
zweiten halbjahr deutlich anders
aufgestellt wird nicht nur aber vor
allem auch mit einer deutlich
relevanteren beteiligung der länder was
haben wir noch gemacht wir haben die
bundesgesundheitsministerium mitgegeben
dass wir ein prognose tool etablieren
wollen damit wir besser als bislang
abschätzen können was die tatsächlichen
kurven impfstoff bedarfen sind damit wir
weder nochmal in die über noch in die
unterversorgung kommen weil auch das
geld ist was an anderer stelle fehlt wir
stärken die pflege vertretung damit die
pflege auch politisch stärker wirken
kann wie wir stärken menschen mit
psychischen erkrankungen
wir werden unserer internationalen
verantwortung gerecht und stocken die
mittel für internationale
gesundheitspolitik auf insgesamt 100
millionen euro all das haben wir im
parlamentarischen verfahren in diesem
haushalt noch zusätzlich erreichen
können aber all das bedeutet
danke kasten
aber all das bedeutet natürlich auch
dieser mega etat den wir dieses jahr
vorfinden diese milliarden die wir da
auch bis zuletzt noch mal oben drauf
geschichtet haben fast nichts davon wird
wirklich nachhaltig verbessere
versorgungsstrukturen zur verfügung
stehen sondern der großteil davon geht
in die in die bewältigung der krise und
das kann natürlich nicht auch die
antwort und die aussage der etats 20 23
und folgende sein deswegen haben wir
auch im haushaltsausschuss uns mit dafür
stark gemacht dass wichtige projekte aus
dem koalitionsvertrag jetzt wirklich in
die umsetzung kommt für dieses jahr
haben wir da den druck vor allen dingen
aus cannabis kontrollgesetz gelegt und
auf den nationalen präventions- plan und
das wird aber nicht das letzte sein bei
denen hat würde ich auch als
haushaltsausschuss in diesen zeiten wo
so unglaublich große mitteln aus dem
haushaltsausschuss für die
sicherstellung einer guten
gesundheitsversorgung aufgebracht werden
müssen selber auch als
haushaltsausschuss ein unglaublich
großes interesse daran haben dass der
reformstau im gesundheitswesen und in
der pflege jetzt auch angegangen wird
deswegen karl lauterbach sie haben nicht
nur im gesundheitsausschuss viele
verbündete sondern auch im
haushaltsausschuss bei wir gemeinsam mit
ihnen dafür sorgen wollen dass dieses
gesundheitssystem nach dieser legislatur
den großen reformstau und großen teilen
bewältigt hat und dass wir dann
tatsächlich auch große gelder werden
eingesetzt haben für eine wirklich
bessere versorgung nicht nur für die
patientinnen und patienten in diesem
land sondern auch deutlich bessere
arbeitsbedingungen für die vielen
millionen beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen in unserem land vielen
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
mittlerweile hat petra pau hier das
präsidium übernommen und sagt ihre
parteifreundin gesine lötzsch von den
linken an stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende haushaltspolitische
sprecherin der linken in unserem
gesundheitssystem arbeiten viele
engagierte menschen
doch unter welchen bedingungen sie geben
auch pflegekräfte und ärzte weil ihn das
alles zu schwer wird geburtsstationen
werden geschlossen krankenhäuser sind
unterfinanziert so darf das nicht
weitergehen
und ich finde es ist auch ein gebot der
stunde dass bund und länder endlich
zusammen arbeiten und nicht immer mit
dem finger auf die länder gezeigt wird
wir haben dazu entsprechende anträge im
haushaltsausschuss gestellt wir brauchen
endlich ein investitionsprogramm in die
krankenhäuser damen und herren herr
lauterbach sie sind seit 7 30
herr lauterbach sie sind seit 2004 in
einer arbeitsgruppe des parteivorstandes
zum thema bürgerversicherung das heißt
also seit mindestens 18 jahren reden sie
über dieses thema zum vergleich nach nur
100 tagen beschließt die große koalition
aller zeiten nämlich aus spd grünen fdp
und der union ein 100 milliarden euro
sonderprogramm für militärische
aufrüstung das ist der falsche
schwerpunkt das ist der falsche weg
meine damen und herren wir
wissen aus jeder statistik wer arm ist
muss er sterben diese ungerechtigkeit
muss endlich ein ende haben und wir
kommen nur aus der dauerkrise wenn wir
unser gesundheitssystem eben nicht mehr
nach kapitalistischen regeln
organisieren gesundheit darf nicht
länger eine wahre sein jeder mensch hat
das recht auf eine gute medizinische
behandeln meine damen und herren herr
lauterbach sie haben es gesagt den
krankenkassen fehlen mindestens 17
milliarden euro auch die
pflegeversicherung ist im minus aber
wenn wir eine bürgerversicherung hätten
in die auch die kapitaleinkünfte
einfließen würden würden wir heute
finanziell deutlich besser dastehen und
wenn sie jetzt sagen sie lassen sich gar
nicht drängen sagen hier doch es muss
sofort etwas geschehen und die
bürgerversicherung wäre die beste lösung
meine damen und herren für eine gute
medizinische behandlung brauchen sie
auch gutes personal das auch gut bezahlt
wird doch die reallöhne sinken die
preise steigen für grundnahrungsmittel
heizung und mieten und wenn jetzt noch
die krankenkassen beiträge erhöht werden
dann bleibt das auch die inflation
weiter an und das wäre die ungerechteste
lösung meine damen und herren stellen
sie sich doch mal einen augenblick vor
wir würden die 100 milliarden euro nicht
zu waffen sondern für ein gerechtes
gesundheitssystem ausgeben wir könnten
verhindern dass die
krankenkassenbeiträge steigen wir
könnten unsere krankenhäuser sanieren
wir könnten die schließung der wurzel
verändern und die menschen die arbeiten
im gesundheitssystem gerecht bezahlen
wir brauchen eine zeitenwende in der
gesundheitspolitik eine solidarische
bürgerversicherung wäre ein wichtiger
schritt dahin vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fdp fraktion hat nun der
abgeordnete karsten klein sagte
[Applaus]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ja die korona krise hat den
einzelplan den haushalt des
gesundheitsministeriums immer noch fest
im griff nach eingestellten mittel in
2020 in höhe von 20,8 milliarden euro
37,6 milliarden euro sind wir jetzt
stand juli juni
2022 bei 64,4 milliarden euro das ist
eine enorme summe und wir diesen zahlen
stecken natürlich auch viele maßnahmen
die geeignet sind um die korona krise zu
bekämpfen um das virus einzudämmen zum
beispiel die impfstrategie wurde schon
mehrmals angesprochen natürlich ist
impfen der zentrale baustein um in diese
krise gegen diese krise anzukämpfen
keine frage aber kein minister wir sind
gemeinsam der auffassung in der ampel
dass man nach drei jahren pandemie schon
beim prognose tool etwas weiter sein
sollte die am anfang und deshalb haben
wir das auch gemeinsam auf den weg
gebracht
das zweite thema was ich ansprechen
wählen wurde schon genannt ist das thema
test verordnung natürlich ist auch
testen wie wichtig in dieser pandemie
aber
bisher ist es so dass eben zum
allergrößten teil der bund diese kosten
für das testen bezahlt und deshalb wird
es nach dem 30 06 kein weiter so geben
zumindest nicht in der form dass der
bund die allerhöchsten kosten für die
tests übernimmt denn die länder sind
hier gefordert der bundesrechnungshof
hat erst vor kurzem noch mal
festgestellt allgemeiner der allgemeine
bevölkerungsschutz ist ländersache
infektionsschutz vor ort ist länder und
kommunale aufgabe und deshalb erwarten
wir auch dass die länder sich nicht nur
zu gesprächen hier in berlin treffen
sondern dass sie dann auch die
finanziellen verantwortung in dieser
pandemie übernehmen
und natürlich richten wir gemeinsam herr
minister auch den blick nach vorne nicht
nur in den herbst führen natürlich ist
wichtig ist dass wir jetzt schon
vorbereitungen treffen dass es nicht so
wieder wie im letzten herbst passiert im
übrigen dass wir unvorbereitet sind das
impfzentren geschlossen sind dass wir
gar nicht starten können wenn es nötig
ist das soll uns nicht wieder passieren
aber wir blicken ja auch schon auf die
frage wie wir uns für die nächste
pandemie aufstellen deshalb haben wir
die bereitschafts verträge verabschiedet
beim thema impfstoffherstellung deshalb
diskutieren wir aber auch wie gehen wir
mit persönlicher schutzausrüstung und da
muss man einfach auch noch mal ein
letztes land machen wir haben in diesem
land
milliarden von persönlicher
schutzausrüstung zu viel geschafft warum
haben wir zu viel geschafft weil länder
kommunen und hilfsorganisationen
parallel zum bund sich selbst eingedeckt
haben und das zeigt einfach hier sind
milliarden von euro in
persönliche schutzausrüstung geflossen
die am ende gar nicht benötigt worden
ist und das darf uns in einer
zukünftigen pandemie nicht wieder
passieren denn dass sie milliarden euro
schulden die zukünftige generation
zurückzahlen müssen die vermeidbar
gewesen wären
und dann komme ich natürlich auch zu dem
wichtigen thema für die nächsten monate
die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung nach
berechnungen es wurde schon gesagt weist
ein defizit im nächsten jahr von 17
milliarden euro 2024 von 21 milliarden
euro und ich möchte zum bedingungen das
mag den ein oder anderen verwundern dass
hat noch einmal das thema krankenhaus
investitionen in den mittelpunkt stellt
denn so einfach nicht dass hier in der
debatte gehört habe ist es eben nicht
die länder finanzieren seit jahren vier
bis fünf milliarden euro hat der
bundesrechnungshof errechnet vier bis
fünf milliarden euro zu wenig in unsere
krankenhausstrukturen und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ist nicht schön
dass wir und es ist richtig und wichtig
dass wir den pflegerinnen und pfleger
applaus zahlen auch den ärztinnen und
ärzten aber die leben das ihn dafür
verantwortlich dass die ordentlichen
arbeitsbedingungen vorfinden das die
moderne strukturen haben und das erwarte
ich von den ländern auch als lehre aus
dieser party mieters ist von den ländern
dass es endlich umgesetzt wird und es
nicht am ende einfach den bund über
geschoben wird denn uns erreichen diese
kosten ja auch bei den betriebskosten
und damit in den gesetzlichen
krankenversicherungen damit auch beim
bundeszuschüssen haushalt und deshalb
muss dieses thema angegangen werden
das zweite thema ist die digitalisierung
der krankenhäuser der kollege dr helge
braun hat es ja zurecht angesprochen
drei milliarden euro hat der bund zur
verfügung gestellt deshalb erwarte ich
dass die länder das jetzt auch umsetzen
und es wäre hervorragend wenn die
kolleginnen und kollegen der union auch
mal ein ernstes gespräch mit ihrem
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten in schleswig
holstein wieder in nordrhein-westfalen
hessen oder in bayern führen würden
vielleicht dass man dann da endlich mal
einen ganzen schritt vorankommt und
dieses problem endlich anpacken
der ampel hat ja gott sei dank jetzt
auch in den haushalt die digitale
gesundheitsagentur hineingeschrieben war
der fdp auch ein sehr wichtiges projekt
mckinsey hat ja errechnet dass uns das
im prozess 42 milliarden euro entlastung
bringen könnte ob das am ende generiert
werden kann oder nicht ist erst mal eine
andere frage aber das zeigt doch dass
sie ein riesen potenzial vorhanden ist
das bisher ungehobenen in unserem
gesundheitssystem liegt und deshalb
müssen wir das kraftvoll jetzt angehen
und wenn wir über die defizite reden
herr minister sie haben dass du recht
angesprochen bei der gkv ich habe vorhin
die defizite ja schon angesprochen mit
17 milliarden euro im nächsten jahr der
an aufwuchs zeigt ja noch mal dass wir
über ein strukturelles defizit drehen
das immer größer wird und weil die union
sich jetzt soll hier schon so ein
bisschen einzigen in der generaldebatte
aber auch heute wieder wirklich noch mal
dran die gesetzgebung die spanische
gesetzgebung aus der letzten
legislaturperiode ist nach berechnungen
in diesem jahr für zwölf milliarden euro
mehrausgaben bei der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung verantwortlich und
deshalb ist es nicht an gesagt dass sie
hier die verantwortung möglichst jedoch
ans haus oder an die ampel rüberschieben
sondern ist auch ihre verantwortung
aufgrund von versäumnissen in der
letzten legislatur verlieren
und deshalb müssen wir gemeinsam mit
dafür sorgen dass das bei dieser reform
1 1 gehalten wird was uns der
bundesrechnungshof auch ins buch
geschrieben hat nämlich der gerechten
lastenausgleich zwischen den
generationen
wir müssen an verschiedenen
stellschrauben drehen auch beim thema
der struktur in der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung damit wir nach einem
ausgewogenen tragbaren kompromiss kommen
wie die gesetzliche krankenversicherung
und auch die pflegeversicherung in
zukunft finanziert wird vielen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
der bundestag debattiert den einzelplan
15 gesundheit
64 36 milliarden euro das sind 11 76
milliarden mehr als im regierungsentwurf
vorgesehen war und
der amtierende minister laut aber hat
gesagt es ist der zweitgrößte time
bundeshaushalt aber er ist auch
notwendig sepp müller für die union
von ihrem haus eine arbeitsplanung
bekommen die vorsah dass bis zum ende
mai
mittlerweile vorbei an pandemie
bekämpfungsgesetz und konzept aufgelegt
wird aus ihrem haus 9 fünfter kann ich
ihnen gerne zur verfügung stellen
wir müssen heute feststellen es ist
nicht da wenn das die taten des karl
lauterbach sind die sie gerade
angekündigt haben dann gute nacht marie
für das gesundheitswesen in deutschland
sie sprechen davon dass wir zusätzlichen
impfstoff beschaffen wollen um auf
zukünftige wellen und varianten vor
gesichert zu sein ja das ist natürlich
richtig aber was machen wir mit den
millionen impfdosen die sie im dezember
zusätzlich versorgt haben die
mittlerweile auf den halben liegen die
nicht verimpft werden können
was ist mit diesen impfdosen was ist mit
den 840 millionen euro die sie jetzt
jetzt in die hand nehmen lieber ampel um
zusätzliche impfstoff zu beschaffen für
varianten die wir noch gar nicht kennen
währenddessen auf der anderen seite noch
millionen impfdosen rumliegen
warum begegnen wir damit nicht im
landarzt problem ein riesenproblem 60
prozent der menschen leben im ländlichen
raum an wissen wie schwierig es ist ein
landarzt zu bekommen von den 840
millionen euro hätten wir über 200
medizinische versorgungszentren im
ländlichen raum bauen können von den 840
millionen euro hätten wir lieber herr
lauterbach über
3000 medizin studienplätze im land
sachsen-anhalt fördern können dass wir
ihre aufgabe gewesen dem landarzt mangel
zu begegnen das ist aufgabe des
gesundheitsministers und sich nicht zu
verbarrikadieren und
dann sehen wir 17 milliarden euro und
sie sagen sie lassen sich dort nicht
treiben januar gesetzte werden sie
treiben wenn bis oktober dieses jahres
keine
finanzierungszusage für die gesetzliche
krankenversicherung kommen wird
beispielsweise durch einen höheren
bundeszuschuss in dem man für
arbeitslosengeld 2 empfänger den
vollständigen beitrag übernimmt der in
ihrem haushalt noch nicht abgebildet ist
den sie heute vorgelegt haben was
bedeutet das dann sagen sie es den
menschen sagen sie es den rentnerinnen
und rentnern die sich am
entlastungspaket vergessen haben das
bedeutet ein prozent
beitragssteigerungen das bedeutet diese
koalition wird 180 euro zusätzlichen
beitrag für rentnerinnen und rentner ein
geben weil sie ihre hausaufgaben nicht
gemacht haben lauterbach
sagen sie es den menschen dort draußen
dass die lösung die nicht einfach es um
himmels willen beiden dialog in der
gesetzlichen pflegeversicherung die
geschlossen werden muss auch auf den weg
gebracht werden kann was das bedeutet
für diejenigen die heute noch nicht von
ihrem entlastungspaket entlastet werden
das bedeutet im nächsten jahr eine
zusätzliche belastung von über 50 euro
für rentnerinnen und rentner weil sie
ihre hausaufgaben nicht gemacht haben ja
lauterbach und dafür regeln wieder
verdienen ich habe die uhr angehalten
sind sie bereit eine frage oder
bemerkung aus der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen zuzulassen ja
maria klein schmeink
nachfrage zu lassen und ich hätte da die
frage wir haben ja ein mittelfristige
finanzplanung auch der aus der letzten
wahlperiode
übernommen und können sie mir damals
sagen wo da die ansätze zum beispiel für
die beiträge von g2 beziehenden waren
können sie mir sagen wo da die ansätze
sind rückstellungen für die großen
rückzahlungen die noch auf uns zukommen
und nirgendwo etatisiert sind aus masken
deals die wir bedienen müssen es ist die
rede von 25 milliarden euro von vor
gericht liegenden verfahren die wir
voraussichtlich wegen schlechter
gestellt vertragsgestaltungen dann
bedienen müssen wo sind diese ansätze
gewesen und welche verantwortung sehen
sie da bei ihrer fraktion und bei dem
minister den der ja diesen haushalt auch
zu verantworten hatte
vielen dank frau kollegin das gibt mir
die möglichkeit noch mal aus dem
koalitionsvertrag der großen koalition
die wir gemeinsam verabschiedet haben zu
zitieren da haben wir uns darauf
verständigt dass arbeitslosengeld 2
empfänger sich also daß wir den beitrag
der arbeitslosengeld 2 empfänger voll
aufstocken und damit auch die
gesetzliche
krankenversicherung mit entlasten und
ich hätte mir natürlich erwartet dass
wir das dann fortsetzung darum bin ich
gespannt ob die ampel das macht weil wir
werden daran festhalten
jetzt bin ich erst mal dran mit meiner
antwort um ihnen darauf noch weiter
ausführen zu können das wäre der erste
punkt wir hatten uns darauf verständigt
und das hätten wir natürlich auch
umgesetzt und lassen nicht irgendwas
zirkulieren was zurückgezogen werden das
punkt nummer 1 punkte nummer zwei
knapp zwei milliarden euro knapp zwei
milliarden euro werden monatlich für
tests ausgegeben zwei milliarden euro
jede monate der bundesrechnungshof hat
zu recht darauf hingewiesen dass das
länder aufgabe ist im größten teil und
es fehlt der fortschritts koalition
anmut das vorzuziehen dass das ausläuft
da hätten sie auch eine
finanzierungsalternative gehabt um
beispielsweise das loch der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung nicht weiter auf
klassen zu lassen was sie machen was sie
mal lieber ampel sie sind nicht die
fortschritts koalition sie sind die
teuer koalition für rentnerinnen und
rentner an diesem land mit ihnen wird
jedes jahr der beitrag steigen und das
ist schade meine sehr geehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen es ist unsere
aufgabe hier den finger in die wunde zu
legen und lieber lauterbach das werden
wir weiterhin tun sie haben gesagt sie
sind ein mann der taten daran werden wir
sie messen verlassen sie sich drauf
[Applaus]
für die spd fraktion hat nun die
kollegin svenja stadler das wohl
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen diebe gäste auf
den tribünen und vor dem bildschirm
herr müller
ich weiß vielleicht bin ich auch falsch
informiert aber das glaube ich nicht
studienplätze vor allen dingen der
medizin auch werden von den ländern
finanziert ich weiß nicht was sie
brauchen
und gesetze
gesetzentwürfe in bezug auf gkv oder
triage ich weiß nicht wo sie die gelesen
haben hier wurden sie bisher nicht zu
geleitet und von daher kann ich auch
nicht darüber diskutieren
der lanz ist nicht das parlament ich
weiß ja nicht was sie da jetzt
verwechseln
[Applaus]
ein extrem hohen haus zeit mit 64
milliarden euro
diese diese höhe hat damit zu tun weil
wir verantwortung übernehmen wir sind da
um die bürgerinnen und bürger zu
schützen vor einem virus und deshalb
haben wir geld in die hand genommen um
impfstoffe einzukaufen zu entwickeln und
auch nach bevor bereitzustellen wir
haben finanzielle unterstützung
geliefert weil test und auch impfzentren
und wir sorgen auch für schutz und
hygiene materialien aber auch eben für
die versorgung von intensivmedizinischer
versorgen und ja es ist jetzt auf zeit
weichen zu stellen für die zukunft für
eine zeit nach coruna und da sitzt eine
expertenkommission und überprüft die
maßnahmen und auf diesen bericht warten
wir und ist auch gut so und er wird uns
zeitnah mit sicherheit dem parlament
zugeleitet nichtsdestotrotz wissen wir
aber jetzt doch schon wer in dieser zeit
besonders gelitten hat und das waren
noch die kinder und die jugendlichen und
eben auch die ältere bevölkerung und
diese erkenntnis gilt es nun eben auch
in maßnahmen umzusetzen um eben
langzeitfolgen von psychischer und
physischen erkrankungen und auch in
bezug auf longo wird entgegen zu wirken
und daher haben wir im haushalt 22 geld
in die hand genommen für die erstellung
eines nationalen
präventionspreis
und zudem investieren wir
mit 13,20 euro auch in
aufklärungsmaßnahmen auf dem gebiet des
drogen und suchtmittelmissbrauch genauso
wie in maßnahmen zur tabakentwöhnung und
wenn sie auch einzeln dieser pandemie
gelernt haben dann ist es dass wir mit
validen daten evidenzbasierte
empfehlungen aussprechen könnten das ist
uns dieses mal leider verwehrt geblieben
und deshalb haben wir ganz bewusst auch
da geld investiert um eine dezentrale
forschungsdaten
infrastruktur auf die beine zu stellen
wir investieren eine million euro für
den aufbau in eine digitale
gesundheitsagentur die soldaten mich nur
sammeln sondern eben auch möglichkeiten
bieten besser vorbereitet zu sein
und digitalisierung im gesundheitssystem
ist wichtig und das ist auch richtig
dass wir das machen so aber auch für die
bürgerinnen und bürger gibt es da
vorteil es gibt nämlich sogenannte
gesundheits apps oder fitness apps jeder
benutzt mindestens eine bin ich mir
sicher von meinen kolleginnen und
kollegen besitzen ja viel rum da hilft
es sport zu machen und diese apps helfen
aber auch jugendlichen an der einen oder
anderen stelle wenn es um professionelle
hilfe geht krankenkassen arbeiten auch
mit raps und im notfall können apps
sogar an der einen oder anderen stelle
helfen sagen oder zeigen was zu tun ist
das sind vorteile die wir nutzen aber
wir müssen auch etwas stärker und
intensiver konstruktiv und kritisch
diese entwicklung im blick haben denn
wenn wir uns das genauer angucken eltern
und auch jugendliche wissen nicht welche
app ist gut und wirkt richtig gerade im
bereich der gesundheit und es ist auch
so was passiert mit den daten das wissen
wir auch nicht da gibt es keinen tüv
siegel oder etwas ähnliches was eltern
und jugendlichen wie eine orientierung
bietet das gilt es zu ändern denn sonst
wird aus einem digitalen vorteil ganz
schnell ein gesundheitlicher nachteil
bewohner hat gezeigt
dass diese vernetzung die wir haben
total gut ist auf der einen seite weil
wir eben forschung nutzen können
weltweit um anhand von erkenntnissen
gemeinsam arbeiten an problemen auch am
fortschritt die fortschritt
voranzutreiben und deshalb ist es für
uns ganz wichtig diese internationale
verantwortung auch zu unterstreichen wir
haben jetzt noch mal mit knapp 174
millionen euro die internationalen
aufgaben des gesundheitssystem
unterstützt davon profitiert unter
anderem der whu habe hier in berlin
dieses zentrum wird international
datenaustausch fördern und wir stärken
die internationale öffentliche
gesundheit mit 100 mio und das ist ein
plus von 13 4 mio und international ist
es so wichtig dass wir vorreiter bleiben
sind und weiterhin werden der etat für
world health summit steigt auf 15
millionen euro das finde ich schon cool
ich freue mich drauf so das ist aber
nicht nur ein lehre die wir aus der
pandemie ziehen sondern dass es ein
bekenntnis zur verantwortung die wir
eben deutschland für deutschland in
einer globalisierten welt übernehmen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dieser
etat ist gewaltig er ist riesig und das
ist gut so denn da steckt eine menge
gesellschaftlicher verantwortung drin
und gleichzeitig auch extrem viel
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten national und
eben auch international und dieser
gesundheitsetat gibt eben sicherheit und
wandel an dieser stelle möchte ich mich
bei meinen haushalts kolleginnen und
kollegen danken das war eine tolle
zusammenarbeit besonders beim
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach und
seinem haus er stand immer rede und
antwort tag und nacht auch seine
mitarbeiter des hauses ich möchte mich
auch bei meinen bei unseren
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
bedanken in den ags und im ausschuss und
ganz besonders bei paula fischotter und
karsten klein für die vertrauensvolle
zusammenarbeit es hat spaß gemacht mit
euch diesen haushalt zu gestalten ich
freue mich schon auf den nächsten aber
jetzt würde ich jeden motivieren diesem
haushalt zuschuss zuzustimmen er ist gut
meine fraktion wird das tool vielen dank
soweit die berichterstatterin für die
spd-fraktion svenja stadler auf sie
folgt der berichterstatter für die
fdp-fraktion
wolfgang eder dass auch alle danksagung
und sonstigen mitteilungen in die
redezeit einzupreisen sind und nicht
hinten drangehängt werden
das wort hat der abgeordnete wolfgang
wille für die fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen der
haushaltsplan für das
bundesgesundheitsministerium umfasst
inzwischen über
64 milliarden euro er ist damit der
zweitgrößte haushalt aller
bundesministerien nur für arbeit und
soziales wird mehr ausgegeben im
vergleich zu 20 21 wächst er noch einmal
um fast 15 milliarden obwohl die korona
krise mehr oder weniger verweist so groß
wie dieser zuwachs allein war der
gesamte gesundheits haushalt all die
jahre bis 20 19 und 14 von 15 milliarden
machte davon damals der zuschuss an die
krankenkassen aus
zur aktuellen steuergeld ausgaben orgien
gehört ganz wesentlich
impfstoffs 7 milliarden euro + reste aus
dem vorjahr wandern dafür in die kassen
der pharmaindustrie
wir kennen ihre begründung herr minister
lauterbach im herbst wollen sie gleich
gegen zwei virenstämme voll im stoff
lager haben ob die vakzine wirksam und
sicher sind ist sehr umstritten höflich
gesagt warum tut es nicht auch eine
grundausstattung plus reservierung von
und beziehungs kapazitäten
um ihr plan führt direkt dazu dass die
halbe impfstoffmenge erneut weggeworfen
oder verschenkt werden sie haben das
vorhin selber eingeräumt der
steuerzahler hat ja und die konzerne
freuen sich
dass für die ziemlich fruchtlose
impfkampagne rund 200 millionen euro
ausgegeben werden sollen 40 mal mehr als
früher für die öffentlichkeitsarbeit hat
auch der rechnungshof kritisiert jetzt
sind diese posten im haushalt zwar
getrennt aber die geldverschwendung ist
mich gestoppt
andere regierung gehen mit den konzernen
übrigens weniger zimperlich um polen hat
erklärt dass man keine weiteren
impfdosen mehr abnehmen oder bezahlen
werden dort zehn dem stoff lager genau
so voll wie hier in deutschland aber
keine spielt mit der angst der menschen
vor dem herbst die interessen der
polnische steuerzahler werden von deren
regierung besser geschützt als die der
deutschen von ihnen
leider passt der impfstoff massen
einkauf auch zu den politischen
gesprächen in diesem hause bei den
haushaltsberatungen war hinter
verschlossenen türen von cdu seite zu
hören das ist doch eine mehrheit für
eine impfpflicht geben diesem ziel dient
auch der cdu antrag ein impf register
einzuführen und dafür 50 millionen euro
bereitzustellen
das heißt diese diskussion die millionen
menschen auf die straße getrieben hat
droht unserem land ein zweites mal und
ich warne ausdrücklich davor die fdp
fraktion wird wieder engagiert und
geschlossen dagegen stimmen
zu warnen ist auch vor machtambitionen
mit denen offensichtlich in der
weltgesundheitsorganisation der whu
gespielt wird versuche die organisation
über einen pandemie vertrag weitgehende
rechte zu übertragen sind vergangene
woche am widerstand afrikanischer
staaten und brasilien gescheitert
deutschland zahlt über die bhu
pflichtbeiträge hinaus in großem umfang
freiwillige mittel und es ist aufgabe
der bundesregierung die interessen
deutschlands selbstbewusst zu vertreten
und einer zentralisierung von
entscheidungen entgegen zu wirken
der gesundheits haushalt meine damen und
herren muss umgehend wieder auf das
übliche maß zurückgeführt werden für
verbesserungen zugunsten der
gesundheitsversorgung ist die afg
fraktion dabei sehr offen den jetzigen
64 milliarden haushalt denen die an
[Applaus]
wolfgang wie levadas als im nächste
redner spricht für die bündnisgrünen
janosch dahmen der gesundheitspolitische
sprecher und sie sehen wir warten auch
auf eine pressekonferenz zu mitteln
staatsvertrag
es ist immer wieder frappierend welch
unglaublichen unfug von der rechten
seite des hauses hier verbreitet wird
verschwörungstheorien über die
weltgesundheitsorganisation die wir mit
gutem grund von deutschland aus stützen
fördern als teil internationaler
verantwortung als teil von vernetzung
als erkenntnis aus dieser pandemie das
nur mit internationaler solidarität ein
global basierendes virus bekämpft werden
kann ich kann auch in gleichem maße nur
davor warnen dass wir in diesem sommer
erneut und zurücklehnen und vorsorge
unter den tisch fallen lassen und wir
verlassen den bundestag an dieser stelle
um zur pressekonferenz ion medien
staatsvertrag zu gehen sehr geehrter
herr kollege braun ausgerechnet die
union gewesen die uns einen ramponierten
gesundheitsetat in dieser legislatur vor
die füße geschmissen hat und wenn wir
uns heute über löcher von morgen
unterhalten dann liegt die antwort in
fehlern der vergangenheit in geld was
über die maßen ausgegeben wurde im
vorsorge finanzpolitischer haushalt
irischer vorsorge die nicht getroffen
wurde und der verantwortung mit der wir
jetzt umgehen dass wir das zur verfügung
stehende mittel im richtigen maße
einsetzen und richtiges maß das bedeutet
dass wir jetzt vorausschauend in der
pandemie indem wir impfstoffe besorgen
in der konfiguration dass sie eben nicht
nur für eine eventualität greifen
sondern für unterschiedliche
virusvarianten die möglich scheinen die
menschen in diesem land schützen können
indem wir dafür sorgen dass die tests
zentren funktionieren die im letzten
jahr nicht durchfinanziert waren wo die
finanzierung märz ausgelaufen war und
die menschen ohne bürgert es da standen
in dem impfzentren im dezember nicht zur
verfügung standen in dem der impfstoff
im januar der gebraucht wurde um die
impfkampagne auszuweiten nicht zur
verfügung stand all das wird hier
vorgesorgt genauso wie notwendige
ausgaben in der aufklärungsarbeit um die
impflücken zu schließen denn das liebe
union verwundert doch sehr dass wenige
wochen nachdem hier im parlament einen
gesetzesentwurf vor lag der als
zentrales element die
informationserfassung zu genesenen
staaten zum impfstatus vorgesehen hat
jetzt plötzlich im rahmen der haushalts
behandlung eine aufgewärmte antrag
vorgelegt ist wo ich mich frage wo war
die union als es um verantwortung der
datenerfassung vor wenigen wochen in
diesem hause hier gingen und wenn wir
nun nach vorne schauen dann bedeutet
vorsorge selbstverständlich auch gute
gesundheitsversorgung jenseits der
pandemie mit dem nationalen präventions-
plan den wir auf den weg bringen bringen
wir maßnahmenpakete auf dem weg die im
bereich sucht die im bereich einsamkeit
die im bereich wiederbelebung
zahngesundheit der alten menschen
wichtige maßnahmenpakete möglich machen
und damit für morgen in den menschen der
gesundheitsversorgung vorsorgen
krankheit vermeiden und die menschen
schützen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen
ich bin unserem bundeskanzler sehr
dankbar dafür dass er gestern noch
einmal klar gemacht hat dass wir alle
hier in dieser zukunfts koalition dafür
stehen dass wir das gesundheitssystem
zukunftssicher aufstellen dass wir unser
sozialversicherungssysteme gut
finanzieren werden dass wir leistungen
auf die die menschen sich in diesem land
verlassen können durch finanzieren
werden keine leistungskürzung
voranbringen werden sondern sie
stabilisieren und kluge reform
wissenschaftsbasierte mit entsprechenden
wissenschaftskommission auf den weg
gebracht haben das ist gut im
gesundheitsministerium das ist
geschlossen in dieser koalition das wird
von der regierung gemeinsam getragen und
in diesem sinne ich freue mich über
diesen klugen vorausschauenden
vorsorgenden haushalt vielen dank auch
an die kollegin des haushaltsausschusses
dankeschön
[Applaus]
für die fraktion die linke hat nun die
kollegin kathrin vogler des
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin hatte
kolleginnen und kollegen herr minister
lauterbach sie haben gerade in ihrer
rede gesagt sie seien ja mehr so ein
mann der tat als ein mann großer worte
und das bezog sich auf die
krankenhausfinanzierung allen ernstes
ist tut mir leid ich musste da lachen
aber ich fürchte den kolleginnen und
kollegen im nordrhein-westfälischen
universitätskliniken die jetzt seit
einem monat dafür streiten dass wir
endlich vernünftige arbeitsbedingungen
und entlastung bekommen den wird das
lachen im halse stecken geblieben sein
als sie das gehört haben denn während in
den gesundheitsberufen hunderttausende
mitarbeitende fehlen und die
gefährlichen zustände für die
patientinnen und die krankmachende
arbeitsüberlastung für die beschäftigten
anhalten kann diese regierung ist nicht
mal hinbekommen die lange versprochene
als kurzfristig am koalitionsvertrag
angekündigte pflegepersonal regelung 2.0
die pr 2.0 auf den weg zu bringen die
das ist doch ein schlag ins gesicht der
pflegekräfte und alle anderen
beschäftigten im gesundheitswesen
17 17 milliarden fehlen in der
gesetzlichen krankenversicherung das ein
dramatisches defizit ja und deswegen
hatten sie herr minister doch ein
finanzierungsgesetz angekündigt das ist
dann aber klammheimlich wieder in der
versenkung verschwunden ich vermute mal
das hat mit ihrem kleinsten
koalitionspartner zu tun
denn für eine auskömmliche finanzierung
der krankenkassen bräuchte ist nämlich
entweder mehr beitragszahlenden also
etwa auch beamte selbstständige und gut
verdienende oder märz steuerzuschüsse
und beides ist mit der fdp
dem freundeskreis der privat
versicherungsunternehmen offensichtlich
nicht zu machen und deswegen werden die
krankenkassen 2023 erhebliche
beitragserhöhungen vornehmen müssen zu
lasten der menschen die gerade sowieso
nicht wissen wie sie haben ende des
monats noch ihre lebensmitteleinkäufe
oder die stromrechnung bezahlen soll und
dafür ich muss diese bundesregierung
endlich etwas tun herr lauterbach
für pflege und gesundheit da soll die
schuldenbremse ab nächstes jahr wieder
gelten aber in einem federstrich 100
milliarden euro neue schulden ins
grundgesetz geschrieben werden für
panzer und kampfflugzeuge
das ist nicht hinnehmbar das macht die
linke nicht mit
für die fdp-fraktion hat nun der kollege
maximilian funke kaiser das boot
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin sehr geehrter herr
bundesminister liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen lassen sie uns über eines der
wichtigsten zukunftsprojekte der ampel
koalition sprechen nämlich die
digitalisierung die beiden unser land in
der digitalisierung des
gesundheitswesens
zurückliegt dass es uns allen spätestens
während der korona pandemie vor augen
geführt worden ganz klar ist wir müssen
zukunftsfähig werden und deswegen
vorneweg wir bringen die digitalisierung
des gesundheitswesens zum wohle der
versicherten
zum wohle der leistungserbringer und zum
wohle der patienten vor an dieser
haushaltsentwurf der ist dafür die
weichenstellung und das bereits auch im
ersten haushaltsjahr und dafür darf ich
auch ganz herzlich den zuständigen
berichterstatter dem karsten klein
stellen der stadt lollar piotta ganz
herzlich danken
was heißt das konkret aus möglich an
drei punkten festmachen punkt eins und
das auch passend zur haushaltsdebatte
das hatte der kollege klein kdm von
schon angesprochen ich möchte noch ein
bisschen tiefer erläutern die
einsparpotenziale durch digitalisierung
bei ja wir haben einen sehr sehr hohen
haushalt hier vorgelegt bekommen um das
mal bildlich vor zumal allein die
realisierung der elektronischen
patientenakte flächen decken würde
einsparpotenziale von bis zu sieben
milliarden euro bedeuten eine
flächendeckende medizinische versorgung
würden zwölf milliarden euro bedeuten
wenn wir mal eine digitale projekte
zusammen nehmen werden wir bei 40
milliarden euro das im somit die wir
angesichts der aktuellen situation der
globalen situation eigentlich wirklich
dringend nötig hätten und herr braun
statt sich hierhin zu stellen und sich
über die zunahme des haushalts etats zu
echauffieren hätten sie lieber in den
letzten jahren genau diese projekte
angehen können wir dann hätten wir das
geld auch zur verfügung gehabt und
deswegen werden wir jetzt nämlich auch
alle digitalen möglichkeiten nutzen und
aus diesem konjunktiv einen indikativ
machen wir schaffen flächendeckend die
elektronische patientenakte
wir ermöglichen die nutzung des rezeptes
wir geben die rahmen für eine
flächendeckende medizinische versorgung
und vieles mehr und was mir dabei
wichtig ist das macht nicht nur haushalt
herrisch sind das ist auch unsere
politische pflicht das kart
erwirtschaftete geld der bürgerinnen und
bürger in eine bessere
gesundheitsversorgung zu investieren
statt weiterhin aus dem fenster zu
werfen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und damit verbunden auch der zweite
punkt die digitalisierung des
gesundheitswesens
führt zu einer maßgeblichen verbesserung
der effizienz und 24 patienten und
leistungserbringer rennen für jeden
einzelnen man muss sich mal vor augen
führen wir leben im jahre 2022 das mag
man nicht glauben wenn man sich über den
digitalisierungsgrad von deutschland
unterhält und noch immer wird mehr zeit
bei der telefonischen suche nach einem
freien arzt als im behandlungszimmer
selbst verbracht noch immer verbringen
die ärzte und die pflegekräfte mehr zeit
mit papierkram als bei den patienten
selbst überlegen sie sich mal wie viel
einsparpotenzial in der zeit wir durch
digitale möglichkeiten hätten
flächendeckung der online-buchungen
digitalen kommunikationswege und ich
gehen noch einen schritt weiter die
frage wie schnell wir mit der
digitalisierung vorankommen dass es auch
eine frage des respekts gegenüber allen
menschen in diesem land denn das hilft
nicht nur den patienten es hilft auch
denjenigen die in den letzten jahren für
uns alle sich während einer pandemie
entschuldigen sie die wortwahl den arsch
aufgerissen haben wir müssen diese
menschen nicht nur wir müssen die
pflegekräfte nicht nur finanziell
unterstützen wir müssen ihnen auch
endlich die arbeit erleichtern liebe
kolleginnen kollegen und punkte
der aus meiner sicht auch mitunter
wichtigste punkt wir schaffen an der
bessere gesundheitsversorgung beklagen
wir uns doch nicht typisch deutsch immer
nur über das was nicht klappt über den
status quo sondern ändern wir doch
endlich mal etwas daran was nicht passt
die digitalisierung und die digitalen
anwendungen die sind nämlich auch kein
teufelszeug es geht nämlich auch nicht
darum dass wir den besuch bei den
ersteren und ärzten abschaffen wollen es
geht darum dass wir digital und analog
smart miteinander vernetzen es geht
darum dass wir die gesundheitsforschung
verbessern es geht darum dass wir die
bestmögliche behandlungsmethode zur
verfügung stellen mit allen technischen
und innovativen mitteln es geht um
verfügbarkeit von versorgung egal wann
und ganz ganz egal wo liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und dieser haushalt der ermöglicht ich
diese digitalen vorhaben hervorheben
möchte ich und des jüdischen
angesprochen natürlich auch den ausbau
der
thematik zu einer digitalen
gesundheitsagentur im eben auch einen
platz zu bauen in deutschland um diese
digitalen transformation in unseren
gesundheitswesens durchzuführen unser
land ist nämlich viel zu lange im
digitalen bereich klein gehalten worden
um diese verlorene zeit wieder
aufzuholen da müssen wir jetzt
entscheidungen treffen wir müssen uns
auch ehrlich machen das wird auch nicht
jedem gefallen letztendlich geht es aber
ausschließlich um das wohl der menschen
in diesem land darum dass wir die
vernetzung die versorgung und die
forschung nutzen um leben zu retten und
dafür werden wir alle nötigen maßnahmen
ergreifen für eine moderne für eine
digitale für eine flächendeckende und
vor allem auch eine faire versorgung
innerhalb unseres gesundheitswesens es
steht viel an und in den nächsten jahren
werden wir genauso viel auch bewegen
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
wird die cdu csu fraktion spricht nun
der abgeordnete tino sorge
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich bin ja mein vorredner dankbar dass
er wenigstens ein bisschen was
inhaltlich zum haushalt gesagt hat
insbesondere zum thema digitalisierung
da könnte ich jetzt stundenlang oder
erzählen auch waren viel richtiges
gesagt ich fand es nur wieder mal schade
dass der bundesgesundheitsminister hier
wieder ihr dass die letzten monate
bereits gemacht hat nur monothematisch
unterwegs war und monothematisch heißt
es ja nur das thema krone adressiert hat
ich hätte mir beispielsweise gewünscht
dass er uns ganz konkret gesagt hätte
wann kommt denn das gkv
finanzierungsgesetz wann kommt denn das
gesetz zur triage wann kommt denn das
neue gesetze die wir digitalisiert
voranbringen da höre ich immer nur
ankündigungen ich weiß nicht ob es
besser ist von der angst minister in den
ankündigungsminister zu wechseln also
ich weiß nicht was besser ist und
deshalb liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
können wir uns natürlich jetzt darüber
streiten was man eventuell hätte besser
machen können aber wir haben das problem
im gesundheitsausschuss oder im
gesundheitsbereich wir können uns ja
nicht mal über dinge schreiben mein
kollege sepp müller hat sie angesprochen
wir würden uns ja gerne über die frage
der finanzierung des systems mit dem bmg
mit dem gesundheitsminister mit ihm mit
der ampel auseinandersetzen aber es gibt
ja nicht mal einen entwurf und wenn denn
mal ein entwurf kursiert stichwort gkv
finanzierungsgesetz dann wird er nachdem
er in die ressortabstimmung in die
verbändeanhörung gegangen ist nach zwei
tagen zurückgezogen und der minister tut
so als hätte er damit überhaupt nichts
zu tun beim triage gesetz haben wir das
selber erlebt und ich finde dass es
langsam etwas unwürdig das sagt nicht
nur wir als opposition sondern die
ganzen akteure im gesundheitswesen nicht
billigen politik
und deshalb glaube ich müssen wir bei
der debatte uns auch mal ein bisschen
ehrlich machen will also wir müssen doch
darüber sprechen wenn wir sagen wir
haben ein strukturelles defizit im gkv
system von 17 milliarden und tendenziell
eher 2024 milliarden dann können wir
doch nicht mantra artig sowie dass der
minister macht immer sagen es wird keine
beitragssatz zugegeben es wird keine
leistungseinschränkungen geben es wird
sich am system nichts ändern und die
vorschläge die er gemacht hat ein
defizit maximal ausbeute von vier bis
fünf milliarden euro also es muss doch
mal jemand sagen woher das geld kommen
soll und da wäre ich ihnen sehr sehr
dankbar lieber herr kollege lothar barth
wenn sie da endlich mal diesen entwurf
vorliegen würden liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und bei der frage der haushaltsberatung
ja sehe ich ein wir müssen vorsorge
betreiben vorsorge heißt aber auch dass
wir uns entscheiden müssen für welche
risiken treffen wir vorsorge und da ist
es glaube ich der völlig falsche weg zu
sagen wir reden über hypothesen die im
herbst eintreten können wir ungarn quasi
impfstoffe für alle eventualitäten die
es gibt wir verpflichten uns vertraglich
jetzt schon in wirklich größenordnung
ist ja angesprochen wurden 830 millionen
allein die impfstoff bestellungen sind
von 2,6 milliarden auf mittlerweile
sechs milliarden euro angewachsen und
wenn wir jetzt schon wissen dass wir im
juni im juli über 100 millionen dosen
hat impfstoffen verwerfen also wegwerfen
müssen dann muss man doch mal darüber
nachdenken wie ein konzept belastbaren
nachhaltig aussehen kann für den herbst
und da reicht es ihnen nicht einfach zu
sagen wer es könnte eventuell eine
killer variante kommen ohne dass das
wissenschaftlich fundiert auch
evidenzbasiert nachgewiesen wird sondern
wir müssen wir müssen auch über konzepte
diskutieren wir haben hier vorschläge
gemacht im rahmen der impfpflicht
debatte haben leider keine mehrheit
bekommen der minister für seine
vorschläge auch nicht und deshalb hoffe
ich dass wir in den nächsten wochen und
monaten außer einer angstmacherei wieder
zu einer konstruktiven thematik auch
beim krone thema zurückkommen und uns
darüber verständigen wie der für den
herbst
aber
das ist vorbei es sei denn sie einigen
sich mit ihrer fraktion dass ihre
fraktion ihn noch weitere redezeit ab
jetzt sind auch über genommen sagt alles
mein kollege registrierten
ausgeschlossen
für die spd fraktion hat die kollegin
heike engel hausboot
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
schüler innen liebe bürgerinnen und
liebe bürger ganz besonders aus meinem
wahlkreis ravensburg und aus dem
bodenseekreis ein anfang ist kein
meisterstück doch guter anfang halbes
glück ich glaube dieses zitat des
österreichischen philosophen an sein
anastasius grün können wir alle
zustimmen ein guter anfang trotz start
in schwierigen zeiten aber gerade
deshalb bin ich sehr froh dass wir beim
gesundheits haushalt eine tolle erste
runde hinbekommen haben dabei haben der
minister und sein haus im grunde zwei
haushalte zu bewältigen zum einen ist
die pandemie leider noch lange nicht
vorbei das zeigt der haushalt auch die
kolleginnen haben es erwähnt 39
milliarden euro werden für die
bekämpfung der pandemie ausgegeben dabei
würde ich mir wünschen dass wir diese
mittel in den kommenden jahren nicht
mehr bereitstellen müssen für den herbst
sind wir vorbereitet der minister hat es
ausgeführt aber in der heutigen
globalisierten zeit müssen wir auch dann
auf weitere epidemische krankheiten
vorbereitet sein wenn wir die aktuelle
terrorlage überwunden haben werden und
auch dafür bringen wir das nötige geld
auf klar ist aber auch dass krankheiten
eben nicht an grenzen halt machen und
weil wir aktuell dazu ganz viele briefe
bekommen
ja wir brauchen eine starke whu wir
brauchen multilaterale ansätze und daher
erhöhen wir auch hier die mittel
und daneben muss auch der reguläre etat
des gesundheitsministeriums
bespielt werden schon vor der pandemie
hatten wir mit steigenden kosten im
gesundheitssystem zu kämpfen besonders
im ländlichen regionen sehen wir wie die
strukturen abgebaut und reduziert werden
in der pflege sind wir schon über der
belastungsgrenze
ohne die tolle und aufopfernde arbeit
der menschen in den gesundheitsberufen
und übrigens auch der pflegenden
angehörigen hätten wir schon lange eine
krise kaum vorstellbaren ausmaß den
pflegenden bin ich dankbar und ich
möchte hier auch ausdrücklich danke
sagen
der minister und seine mitarbeiter innen
und die kolleginnen im
haushaltsausschuss haben trotz diese
doppelbelastung hervorragendes geleistet
kaum ein land auf der welt kann so gut
durch die krise wie deutschland auch
wenn es richtig eng wurde ist unser
gesundheitssystem nicht
zusammengebrochen und
gleichzeitig entwickeln wir unser
gesundheitssystem fort und machen es
gibt für das einundzwanzigste
jahrhundert die basis dafür bildet ein
guter haushalt natürlich haben wir uns
in der spd fraktion über einige aspekte
besonders gefreut weil das meiste schon
gesagt wurde jetzt einfach im
schnelldurchlauf wir stärken die
digitalisierung im gesundheitswesen wir
bauen die decke matic zu einer digitalen
gesundheitsagentur aus und wir stellen
die notwendigen mittel bereit in der
drogenpolitik haben wir uns viel
vorgenommen wir werden den
cannabiskonsum
entkriminalisieren und legalisieren das
ist längst überfällig
es ist aber auch klar dass durch die
neue verfügbarkeit auch risiken risiken
im gesundheitsbereich entstehen können
und dafür müssen wir uns gut aufstellen
und deswegen stärken wir gleichzeitig
die mittel für die suchtprävention
die globale gesundheit habe ich eingangs
schon erwähnt nicht nur in der pandemie
müssen wir mehr verantwortung übernehmen
deswegen habe ich mich auch sehr gefreut
dass wir haben es gestern im einzelplan
23 gehört dass wir zum beispiel die
mittel für die gavi die globale imf
allianz und den globalen fonds zur
bekämpfung von aids tuberkulose und
malaria erheblich gesteigert haben und
dass wir auch verpflichtungen für die
nächsten jahre eingegangen sind einen
punkt möchte ich hier aber noch erwähnen
der paragraph 219 er wird bald
geschichte sein und wenn es nach mir
geht wird es den paragrafen 218 noch in
dieser legislatur ähnlich ergehen freie
information kann nur ein erster
wichtiger schritt dahin sein denn
gebärfähigen menschen wieder das volle
recht am eigenen körper zu geben ein
guter anfang ist geschafft das halbe
glück haben wir und ich freue mich auf
die nächste haushalts runde und ich habe
die 30 sekunden auch noch eingeholt und
sagt vielen dank
vielen dank
für die fdp-fraktion hat nun der
abgeordnete kai uwe ziegler das wort
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte haben desto lauterbach nach
knapp 50 milliarden im letzten jahr nun
ein etat von 64,4 milliarden euro
64,4 milliarden das sind fast 40
milliarden euro mehr als 15 milliarden
aus dem jahr 2009 10 und im zweifelsfall
lautet die erklärung für diese
gigantischen aufwuchs immer corona
deshalb hier noch mal kurz die eckdaten
für die letzten beiden jahren hatten wir
im jahr 2009 10 noch gut 19,2 millionen
fälle in den krankenhäusern waren es
2020 und 2021 nur noch 16,7 millionen
fälle das sind also 2,5 millionen fälle
weniger in den krankenhäusern pro jahr
von diesen nur 16,7 millionen fällen
waren um 2020
111.000 und 2021
276.000 wegen corona in den
krankenhäusern das waren keine zwei
prozent wir hatten also keine
überlastung sondern der massive
unterauslastung in unseren
krankenhäusern
ein 64,4 milliarden euro etat mit der
begründung corona ist deshalb abzulehnen
kleines beispiel aus dem richtigen leben
gefällig in unserem kommunalen
gesundheitszentrum bitterfeld wolfen
schließt im märz 2020 die geburts und
frauenklinik angeblich aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen
jetzt nicht mehr benötigten 20 betten
werden für 24 kommunen patienten frei
gehalten das bringt 560 euro pro tag und
bett 11.000 euro täglich
patienten auf dieser station über monate
eine geburtsklinik können wir uns nicht
leisten leerstand aber wird finanziell
honoriert
der kreistag von anhalt-bitterfeld
spricht sich für den wiedereröffnung
dieser klinik aus und schließt sogar ein
budget für die anlauf finanziert
ergebnis das land sachsen anhalt sowie
das spd geführte gesundheitsministerium
blockieren die wiedereröffnung dieser
klinik ist zum heutigen tag das ist die
aktuelle gesundheitspolitik hier den
etat mehr als vervierfachen aber für die
daseinsvorsorge in der fläche ist kein
geld da und das ist eine schande meine
damen und herren
er hat die kolleginnen kollegen wie wäre
es denn zum beispiel den mitarbeitern in
den gesundheitsberufen dauerhaft mehr
geld zu geben statt einen einmaligen
pflege bonus
wir könnten aber auch die
gebührenordnung der ärzte novellierung
die letzte anpassung ist noch von 1996
und die gebühren werden immer noch in
d-mark ausgewiesen das und vieles andere
mehr würden wir vorbehaltlos
unterstützen aber diesen 460 milliarden
euro kampf unseres gesundheitsministers
lauterbach der wie don quichote weiter
unermüdlich gegen bewohner wenn man
reitet den durch unsere fraktion ganz
sicher nicht mittragen statt unter dem
deckmantel corona die klinikkonzerne
test center betreiber und die
pharmaindustrie immer reicher zu machen
lassen sie uns lieber dieses geld in die
gesundheit unserer bürger investieren
vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der abgeordnete dietrich
mond stadt für die cdu csu fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen verehrte damen
und herren
ja herr minister sie haben recht dass
dieser haushalt ein haushalt der krise
ist ja ist vor allem ein haushalt der
krise ihres hauses das zieht sie hier
ein roter faden durch diesen haushalt
das gravierende probleme im
gesundheitsbereich hier nicht abgebildet
sind und damit liegt die befürchtung
nahe dass sie auch nicht angegangen
werden herr minister ich darf hier
nochmal die mdr die medical device
regulation ansprechen hierzu haben meine
fraktion um mich zahlreiche besorgte
anfragen erreicht nicht nur durch viele
kleine und mittelständische unternehmen
sondern vor allem erste und patienten
sind von der neuen regelung massiv
betroffen bis hin zu lebensbedrohenden
konsequenzen für manche patienten rund
25.000 zertifizierung für
medizinprodukte werden bis zum ende der
übergangsperiode im mai 24 benötigt doch
es können pro jahr ca 6000
bescheinigungen durch die sogenannten
benannten stellen ausgestellt werden
also in zwei jahren circa 13.000
bescheinigungen wenn jetzt nichts
unternommen wird verschwinden mitte des
jahres 24 bis zu 40 prozent der derzeit
noch genutzten medizin produkte vom
markt
meine damen und herren stellen sie sich
einmal vor wenn ihr kind dringend zum
beispiel in der kinderkardiologie ein
herzkatheter benötigt doch der katheter
jenes seit langer zeit gibt kann nicht
verwendet werden weil er nicht
zertifiziert ist ihr kind könnte nicht
behandelt werden und gegebenenfalls
gravierenden gesundheitlichen folgen der
minister das können wir doch der
bevölkerung nicht erklären meine damen
und herren
die zeit rennt uns davon der
zertifizierungsprozess bei den mandanten
stellen dauert im durchschnitt 18 monate
die unternehmen brauchen jetzt aktuell
kleid was politisch hier und in der eu
entschieden wird und wenn wir nicht
weltpolitisch gegenüber der eu aktiv
werden verlieren wir geschätzt zehn
prozent insbesondere der kleinen und
mittelständischen unternehmen und ca 40
prozent der zugelassenen medizinprodukte
herr minister sie müssen jetzt handeln
meine damen und herren
die regierung hat uns erklärt
umfassendes präventionsmaßnahmen in den
vordergrund rücken zu wollen der
schlüssel zur bekämpfung von
krebserkrankungen von bluthochdruck und
von der volks erkrankungen diabetes
mellitus liegt nicht allein investoren
therapien und medikamenten sondern auch
in prävention und aufklärung der
bevölkerung
da frage ich mich warum die ampel
koalition hier nicht mehr tut im
haushaltsplan soll für die bekämpfung
des diabetes mellitus nur drei millionen
euro jährlich fortgeschrieben werden das
ist die festschreibung des status quo
ohne inflationsausgleich keine
weiterentwicklung
gemeinsam haben wir als union mit der
spd in der letzten legislaturperiode
einem umfassenden antrag zur einführung
einer nationalen diabetes strategie
mehrheitlich hier im bundestag
beschlossen was ist aus diesem antrag
geworden warum wird diese strategie in
diesem haushalt nicht unterlegt damit
droht auch hier ein nicht zu
verantwortender stillstand meine damen
und herren auch ein anderes wichtiges
vorhaben das in der letzten
legislaturperiode begonnen wurde wird
jetzt nicht in der erforderlichen
intensität umgesetzt der minister ich
frage sie was passiert mit dem
nationalen endoprothesenregister ein
register dass die operation daten der
krankenhäuser sammelt und analysiert
die transformation dieses privat
aufgebauten registers in den
öffentlichen bereich droht zu scheitern
die untätigkeit des ministeriums und
damit ihre untätigkeit herr minister
verursacht eine mangelnde datenerfassung
die vielfältigen aussage möglichkeiten
dieses registers gehen damit verloren
auch hier finden sich im haushalt keine
ansätze insgesamt lässt sich festhalten
dass diese haushaltsansätze keine
verbesserung für die gesundheit der
menschen in deutschland erkennen lassen
im gegenteil sie haben einen sind ein
rückschritt vor allem in den von mir
angesprochenen bereichen den haushalt
leben wir vielen dank
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun dr armin grau das wort
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
beschäftigte im deutschen
gesundheitswesen herr braun sie äußerten
in ihre rede sorge um die deutschen
krankenhäuser müssen sich doch die frage
gefallen lassen warum sie die vielen
jahren nicht genutzt haben als cdu eine
krankenhausstrukturen krankenhaus
finanzierungsreform zu machen die
deutschen krankenhäuser krisenfest
gemacht hätte ich habe die pandemie die
leider nicht vorbei ist im krankenhaus
zwei jahre lang mit erlebt und weiß wie
hart der kampf aller beschäftigten am
krankenbett war auch wenn die herren und
damen auf der rechten seite das alles
nicht verstehen und wahrhaben wollen und
ich bin weiterhin in kontakt mit den
kolleginnen und höre ihre sorgt aufgrund
des hohen krankenstands des
fachkräftemangels und der dadurch nicht
besetzt waren stellen in vielen
krankenhäusern dürfen aber zum beispiel
ärztliche stellen derzeit auch nicht
besetzt werden weil die geschäftsführung
sich sorgen machen die krankenhäuser
könnten sich nicht erholen von den
corona bedingten fallzahl einbrüchen die
stationären behandlungszahlen lagen 20
21 rund 14 prozent unter denen von 20 19
und das betrifft auch schwere notfälle
soweit also die pressekonferenz nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit hendrik
wüst malu dreyer und franziska giffey
und wir sind zurück im deutschen
bundestag hier debattieren die
abgeordneten immer noch über den etat
des
bundesgesundheitsministers karl
lauterbach
64 36 milliarden euro soll ihm in diesem
jahr zur verfügung stehen das ist ein
rekord etat für das
bundesgesundheitsministerium
grund dafür ist natürlich die korona
pandemie auch deswegen hofft der
bundesfinanzminister dass es im nächsten
jahr anders aussieht da soll das
bundesgesundheitsministerium nur noch 19
milliarden euro ausgeben allerdings
wissen wir auch dass die pandemie
schlecht vorherzusehen ist in der
debatte geht es hier also deswegen auch
um die bekämpfung der korona pandemie
aber auch um themen die auch in anderen
etats schon angesprochen wurden wie zum
beispiel die digitalisierung stichwort
ist in diesem etat natürlich die
elektronische patientenakte
aber auch sonstige
datenerfassungen zum beispiel auch ein
nationales register das fordert zum
beispiel auch die union dass ein
nationales infra gäste aufgebaut und
betrieben wird als eine mögliche option
der vorsorge für den herbst auch das
haben hier mehrere abgeordnete
angesprochen inwieweit hier vorsorge
getroffen werden kann für eine mögliche
neue corona welle die ja doch im herbst
droht der größte gesundheitsposten ist
natürlich auch im etat hier die
bekämpfung der korona pandemie die
krankenkassen sollen dort mehr geld
bekommen und ich habe schon angesprochen
die union fordert hier ein im register
hatte zu auch ein änderungsantrag hier
eingereicht und für die union spricht
jetzt simone burkhart sie sitzt im
gesundheitsausschuss
wir debattieren heute über den haushalt
eingeplant 15 wir können hier sehen dass
vieles gut gemeint ist nicht alles gut
gemacht und erst recht nicht geplant ist
die jahre der pandemie haben gewirkt wie
ein brennglas und wie ein
brandbeschleuniger in nahezu allen
sektoren wurde dringender reformbedarf
offenkundig das gilt sowohl für den
öffentlichen sektor wie auch für den
gesundheitssektor
für den staat sollte aber gelten dass
die verantwortlichen in der jetzigen
regierung und damit heute und jetzt die
zeichen der zeit erkennen die nötigen
lehren daraus ziehen und überhaupt
endlich anfangen zu handeln und wichtige
weichenstellung unter neuen vorzeichen
mit der erfahrung durch die pandemie
endlich einleiten
die kommenden generationen drohen schon
jetzt von der exklusiven von den
explodierenden kosten völlig erdrückt zu
werden und wenn wir uns jetzt den
haushalt anschauen gibt es ein
strukturelles defizit
welches auch nach aussagen des
bundesministers in der vergangenheit
durch eine erhöhung von beiträgen
refinanziert werden soll damit belasten
sie die menschen die beschäftigten und
vor allem die unternehmen zusätzlich das
kann nicht wirken muss sein mögen so
starten sie eine frage oder punkt aus
einer nation bündnis 90 die grünen
wir bewegen hier mittlerweile so viel
geld in diesem system wir haben kein
einnahmeproblem wir haben ein
ausgabeproblem sie sind jetzt und hier
die regierung gehen sie endlich die
themen richtig an wir müssen effizienter
werden im gesundheitssektor und deshalb
sage ich jetzt und hier gehen sie das
thema
krankenhausfinanzierung an und die damit
verbundene ambulant easy hrung von
leistungen gehen sie das
präventionsgesetz an es ist wichtig
zivilisationskrankheiten zu vermeiden
wir haben erkrankungen wie krebs
diabetes bluthochdruck
wir haben dadurch viel mehr kranke und
tote als durch corona es gibt also auch
noch andere themen die wir bespielen
müssen
meines erachtens werden damit die
schwerpunkte nicht richtig gesetzt und
wie gesagt hören sie bitte auf sich
immer nur mit dem thema corona zu
beschäftigen weil die menschen haben
auch noch andere demokratien
gesundheitssektor die sie bewegen und
das system muss funktionieren wir haben
wesentlich andere sorgen in diesem
bereich
was sie wir planen ist keine
zukunftsfähige politik gegenüber unseren
kindern und enkelkindern und nicht
gerecht somit setzten sie das geld
effektiv ein und damit können sie die
beitragszahler entlasten und das ist
auch die richtige qualität für unser
gesundheitswesen fangen sie an ihrer
arbeit zu machen nehmen sie die prozesse
in den blick und denken sie bitte vor
allem an die beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen vielen dank für euer
auf messen können
sogar simone borchert heike behrens ist
für die sozialdemokraten hier im
deutschen bundestag die obfrau im
gesundheitsausschuss und nächste redner
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja frau
borchardt wir erkennen die zeichen der
zeit schritt um schritt geht uns und rat
schutz koalition die großen struktur
aufgaben an und wir stärken die
gesundheitsversorgung bei uns im land
und auch darüber hinaus und wir wappnen
uns für zukünftige herausforderungen
im zentrum unserer anstrengung steht die
pflege der pflege bonus für den wir eine
milliarde euro in diesem haushalt
bereitstellen ist ein spürbares zeichen
der anerkennung aber es ist nur ein
kleiner erster schritt denn pflegekräfte
brauchen nachhaltige verbesserungen sie
müssen sich auf gute arbeitsbedingungen
auf ordentliche personalschlüssel und
gute bezahlung verlassen können und da
bleiben wir konsequent brandl
darum sorgen wir dafür dass die
profession pflege endlich den
stellenwert in unserem gesundheitssystem
bekommt der ihrer schlüsselrolle
entspricht wo immer über gute versorgung
geredet und entschieden wird da gehört
die pflege mit an den verhandlungstisch
und zwar auf augenhöhe mit der
ärzteschaft und den krankenkassen
und damit der deutschen
der die fachliche expertise der pflege
bündelt seine stimme in den gremien der
selbstverwaltung kraftvoll einbringen
kann erhält er mit dem heutigen
haushaltsbeschluss endlich die nötige
finanzielle ausstattung immerhin in der
größenordnung von 900.000 euro
ja ich bin richtig stolz dass unser
jahrelanges bemühen um eine stark und
der pflege profession
unser in unserem gesundheitssystem heute
endlich auch seinen materiellen
niederschlag findet in diesem
haushaltsplan mit diesen mitteln kann
der deutsche pflegerat seine
geschäftsstelle stärken er kann man
regeln bei als regelmäßiger
ansprechpartner für politik und medien
seine aufgabe verantwortungsvoll
wahrnehmen und bekommt dafür eben die
notwendigen ressourcen um auch durch
wissenschaftliche stellungnahmen
kontinuierlich an gesetzgebungsverfahren
mitwirken zu können ob es um die
anstehende krankenhaus reform geht oder
um die weiterentwicklung der
pflegeversicherung wir brauchen die
erfahrung und expertise der pflege und
deshalb wünschen wir uns als spd eine
starke politische vertretung der pflege
wichtig bleibt aber auch über den
tellerrand hinauszuschauen das fällt
ihnen ganz offensichtlich immer noch
schwer denn gesundheit und wohlergehen
hängen ganz wesentlichen davon ab wie es
uns gelingt auch über ländergrenzen
hinweg zusammenzuarbeiten
nicht nur in der an dem i die uns das
aber sehr deutlich gezeigt hat wie
notwendig das ist das betrifft aber
genauso fragen wie welternährung oder
vor allem auch den klimawandel
deutschland 80 mit seinem engagement für
globale gesundheit international ein
hohes ansehen erarbeitet
der die anregung zum global action plan
kam von der kanzlerin die großen das
große engagement beim impfstoff vorteil
mechanismus der whu kovats ist wirklich
ein markenzeichen von deutschland
geworden genauso auch wie die großartige
beteiligung beim globalen vor oder auch
der vorhin schon genannte world health
summit der eben für die globale
gesundheit der treffpunkt weltweit hier
in berlin geworden ist ich bin froh dass
wir es mit diesem haushalt schaffen
unsere verantwortung in einer
globalisierten welt weiter mit großem
einsatz gerecht zu werden und zwar
ressort übergreifend denn maßgebliche
haushaltstitel für globale gesundheit
sind auch im haushalt des kanzleramtes
verwurzelt oder eben auch beim bmz und
besonders wichtig ist mir die
aufstockung der mittel für die
weltgesundheitsorganisation denn wir
müssen
wir müssen politisch alles tun um sie in
ihrer leitenden und koordinierenden
funktionen zu stärken sie ist die
instanz für pandemievorsorge und krisen
management aber wie alle organisationen
der vereinten nationen kann die whu nur
so stark sein wie ihre mitgliedsstaaten
dies zulassen und wollen und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen deshalb begrüße
ich sehr dass wir unter der g7
präsidentschaft von deutschland gerade
ein klares bekenntnis für eine bessere
aus- finanzierung durch die
mitgliedsbeiträge aller staaten
abgegeben haben
damit wirklich euro schlagkräftiger und
unabhängiger liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen als fortschritts koalition
gestalten wir den aufbruch in der
gesundheitspolitik und entwickeln
strukturen die über die vier jahre einer
legislaturperiode hinausreichen werden
bei uns in deutschland und auf globaler
ebene
nur so können geht echte
modernisieren und vor allem echte
vorsorge für die zukunft vielen dank
frau präsidentin ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit
stefan pischinger
arbeitet neben all seiner tätigkeit als
abgeordneter im deutschen bundestag und
manchmal auch noch als arzt in bayern
aber ich wenn er hier ist sitzt er im
gesundheitsausschuss
wie sie sicher schon alle mitbekommen
haben hat der fc bundestag erstmals seit
elf jahren wieder den parlamentariern
meisters auch den kindern geworden
besonderes lob gebührt dabei meine
mannschaftskollegen dem spd
staatssekretär machen und ärzte mehr der
nicht nur als spieler sondern auch als
trainer erheblich zu diesem erfolg
beigetragen hat lieber machen und
erholen nicht gut sondern verletzungen
wenn man wenn man karl lauterbach rolle
in der gesundheitspolitik in die
fußballer sprache übersetzen müsste
würde ich sagen dass er weder spieler
noch trainer noch spieler drehen ein bmg
ist er ist ein kommentator von der
seitenauslinie der alles besser weiß
aber nichts besser macht karl lauterbach
nutzt sein ministerbüro scheinbar als
reine studierstube für studien geht
seinen beamten aus dem weg kommt fast
nicht in den gesundheitsausschuss und
hat seinen pressesaal des tv studio von
markus lanz verlegt nun wird deutlich
was die spd wahrscheinlich schon lange
wusste nämlich dass unser herr professor
aus köln leider nicht die führungskraft
zu entwickeln scheint die ein
bundesminister täglich zu beweisen muss
lauterbach ich frage sie können
oder wollen sie den dauer krisen modus
als kleiner krone minister nicht
abstellen hat man hat bei ihnen fast den
eindruck als ob sie mit ihren schwarz
malerischen presse äußerungen zu kroner
ihre bislang schwache bilanz an
gesetzesentwürfen und verordnungen zu
übertünchen versuchen nach nur 16
monaten amtszeit konnte entspannt 16
konkrete gesetzesentwürfe vorweisen nach
sechs monaten karl lauterbach hatten wir
nur einen nicht coroner bezogenen
gesetzesentwurf aus den untiefen des bmg
in der minister gleich wieder kassiert
hat nämlich den referentenentwurf zur
finanziellen stabilisierung der
gesetzlichen krankenversicherungen vom
vierten märz bei aller notwendigkeit der
pandemie bekämpfung 0 gesetzesentwürfe
zur nachhaltigen gestaltung unseres
gesundheitsminister sind einfach zu
wenig herr minister
stattdessen liefern sie unabgestimmte
alleingänge um widersprüche in ihrem
eigenen agieren ist die kündigen anfang
april die isolationsschicht für krone
infizierte komplett aufheben zu lassen
nur um diese ankündigung kurz darauf bei
markus lanz und in der folgenden nacht
per twitter wieder einzukassieren anfang
mai ziehen sie ihren gesetzesentwurf zur
theater zurück der die behandlungs
reihenfolge in den kliniken kriegen
sollte ausgerechnet am ostersonntag
waren sie in den medien vor angeblichen
killer krone varianten um diese große
test in keiner wissenschaftlichen
unterlegten aussage dann wieder
kleinlaut relativieren zu müssen im
frühjahr bestellen sie munter neue
impfstoffe für corona wellen die noch
gar nicht absehbar sind jetzt haben wir
überschüsse und 70 millionen dosen und
zusätzliche kosten von knapp drei
milliarden euro apropos es impfstoffe
den medien nämlich im
gesundheitsausschuss sind sie ja nicht
dass sie nun 240.000 impfstoff gegen den
affen pockenvirus bestellt haben
übrigens den eines us-herstellers der in
europa noch gar nicht zugelassen ist es
wäre außerdem gut herr minister wenn sie
den besorgten bürgern heute versichert
hätten dass sie keine impfpflicht gegen
die affen brocken auf den weg bringen
wollen jetzt und hier haben sie die
möglichkeit allen
verschwörungstheoretikern diesbezüglich
den wind aus den segeln zu nehmen hören
sie endlich auf der a8 jedoch
kommunikationsfehler immer neue stoffe
ihre kampagnen zu liefern herr minister
lauterbach bitte seien sie in zukunft
mehr teamspieler und geben sie benötigt
ihren staatssekretären mal einen pass
damit wenigstens sabine dittmer oder
edgar franke einen wichtigen treffer zur
lösung wichtiger gesundheitspolitische
themen landen können vielen dank
stefan pischinger war dass damit kommen
wir zur letzten rednerin zu diesem etat
auch sie ist von beruf ernsten
kirstenpfad gonther von bündnis 90 die
grünen hier im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
gesundheitspolitik ist ja darum so toll
weil sie so elementar ist für jeden
einzelnen menschen für frauen männer
alle geschlechter von ganz jung bis ganz
alt wir alle sind darauf angewiesen dass
wir ein gutes gesundheitssystem haben
und wir brauchen nicht nur eine gute
versorgung die im krankheitsfall
verlässlich ist sondern eine politik die
gerade in in zeiten prävention und
gesundheitsförderung in das zentrum
stellt und darum ist es gut dass wir den
nationalen präventions- plan
ausgestattet haben aber auch klimaschutz
ist gesundheitsschutz effektiver
klimaschutz senkt signifikant das risiko
für weitere kann dem leben
und eine haushaltsdebatte liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und die vielen
großen zahlen die wir heute gehört haben
die sind trotzdem manchmal ganz schön
abstrakt und da ist es sinnvoll dass wir
uns noch mal vor augen führen bei der
finanzierung der krankenversicherung
geht es eben nicht nur um diese großen
milliarden summen sondern es geht im
kern um unser solidarsystem dass die
menschen im ernstfall nicht alleine
lässt
und besonders schwer und chronisch
kranke insbesondere auch für psychisch
kranke ist das grundlegend und darum ist
es so wichtig dass wir im
koalitionsvertrag und die stärkung der
seelischen gesundheit auf die fahnen
geschrieben haben die drei großen krisen
die klimakrise die korona pandemie und
jetzt der schreckliche krieg gegen die
ukraine die zerren an den nerven die
belasten unser aller seelen und
infolgedessen das muss uns bewusst sein
wird der bedarf für psychosoziale
versorgung für psychotherapie noch
steigen das heißt wir müssen jetzt den
akuten bedarf abdecken und für die
zukunft vorbeugen
wir erhöhen den zuschuss an die aktion
psychisch kranke um
100.000 euro für die entstigmatisierung
psychiatrische erkrankung ist es
unerlässlich die expertise von experten
aus erfahrung von psychiatrie erfahren
mit einzubeziehen und hierauf werden wir
und müssen wir auch brauchen und auch
die fortsetzung des psychiatrie dialog
sowie die stärkung der suizidprävention
finanziell sichern und was mich
abschließend besonders freut und wofür
viele menschen sich über jahre engagiert
haben ist dass wir mit diesem haushalt
den einstieg in kontrollierte freigabe
von cannabis einläuten kohle ist ich
habe die uhr angehalten gestatten sie
eine frage des kollegen autos genau
ist der bolide hier in der linken
ja das gestand ich habe ich darf diesen
einsatz noch zu ende ich habe die uhr
angehalten und sie an erstellt jetzt
entweder die frage oder es geht weiter
dann stellen sie bitte die frage und
dann
ja es ist eine frage an die letzte
rednerin der koalition sie haben gerade
gesagt sie haben die zahlen sind sehr
abstrakt im haushalt die für die
gesundheitsplan natürlich auch für
andere pläne vorliegen ich weise noch
einmal darauf hin und das wundert mich
dass niemand auf diese frage die aus
verschiedenen oppositionsfraktionen
eingegangen ist beantwortet hat es wird
sehr sehr konkret wenn wir eine lücke
haben für die versicherten von 14
milliarden euro die auszugleichen ist
von den menschen die hier jeden tag
arbeiten und es wird eine lohnkürzung
seien die spätestens ende des jahres bei
den menschen wirklich ankommen wird in
der jetzigen situation möchte ich noch
einmal darum bitten und fragen wie wird
die sehr sehr sehr konkrete situation
für die menschen in dem land geändert
werden wenn sie was wollen sie tun dass
das waren menschen am ende nicht ankommt
was hier von uns bislang nicht
ausgeglichen würde und was ich von 17
milliarden euro am ende des jahres bei
den menschen niederschlägt
die frage von a-tec alpina aus der
linksfraktion
ein riesenproblem dass wir 18 milliarden
defizit in der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung haben grund ist
nicht etwa zentral die pandemie sondern
grund zählt relevante fehlstellung auch
gesetzliche dinge die die union auf den
weg gebracht hat die dafür geführt haben
dass wir dieses strukturelle defizit
haben das ist erstmal dass wichtige so
jetzt ist es jetzt ist es an uns die wir
das geschafft haben
diese jetzt ist es an uns die wir das
von ihnen geerbt haben dieses defizit
auszugleichen und dafür wird es lösungen
geben unserer lösung die weder die
gesetzlich versicherten belasten noch zu
leistungskürzungen führen
und jetzt waren wir gerade ein sehr
relevanter punkt und wir waren gerade wo
sie die frage gestellt haben bei der sie
haben sehr erfreulichen botschaft dass
wir den einstieg in die kontrollierte
freigabe von cannabis jetzt einläuten
und damit nicht nur die jahrzehntelange
ungerechtigkeiten überwinden sondern
endlich den jugend und gesundheitsschutz
sterben und deswegen haben wir die
präventionsmittel wieder auf das dorf
und eine million euro für begleitende
maßnahmen zur cannabis legalisierung
eingeplant und wir haben ganz deutlich
gemacht mit der ampel
koalition es ist wichtig dass wir viele
akteurinnen einbeziehen und das der
drogenbeauftragte ein
konsultationsprozess durch wird aber
dann muss auch verbindlich noch in
diesem jahr ein gesetzentwurf zur
kontrollierten freigabe von cannabis
durch die bundesregierung vorgelegt
werden und damit das gelingt müssen sie
auch nur jetzt stellen höchste
katholische die projektgruppe kann ein
bisschen bmg vorgelegt jetzt kann die
arbeit losgehen butter bei die fische
ich danke fürs zuhören
ich schließe die aussprache wir kommen
zur abstimmung über den einzelplan 15
bundesministerium für gesundheit in der
ausschuss fassung hierzu liegt ein
änderungsantrag der fraktionen der
cdu/csu auf drucksache
2050 vor in diesem änderungsantrag
fordert die union das eben ein
nationales register aufgebaut wird und
betrieben wird die cdu csu fraktion und
die fraktion linke wer stimmt dagegen
die
koalitionsfraktionen und die fraktion
wer enthält sich niemand der
änderungsantrag ist abgelehnt
wer stimmt für den einzelplan 15 in der
ausschuss fassung so und damit kommen
wir jetzt hierzu in der ersten
abstimmung
64,36 milliarden euro soll der etat von
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach betragen unter anderem um
krankenkassen zu unterstützen die ein
gewaltiges finanzierungsdefizit in der
korona pandemie haben um die impfzentren
zu finanzieren aber auch um zb corona
impfstoffe beschaffen zu können